got a crown
[Music]
the
you're a great singer oh yeah
so evelyn yeah so i found you again on
the street here in
line here in san francisco
yeah what was that you were smoking when
i found you what drew me here that's
uh cocaine it's for
teaching illiterate mothers how to
handle an obnoxious situation
the oblong boy wearing jewelry on his
chest that looks like a knife
when he picks up his thick cigarette
either effusion of alcohol
the red hairs pubing
those are called pubes they itch all the
time you have to take a really rough
surface
even a rock from a lava or
two crushed cubes and not that
white thing that the black boys play
with
they like to teach white girls how to
take
uh cigarette boxes and pull them apart
and that
pulls them into their football and
so i scratched my pubes with a
toilet paper cleaner and i call it a
toothbrush
because my face is so white it looks
like
water and um
when i left they go i
left a uh
puddle behind and
i was with my father-in-law my mother
said you can't get married because and
she sniffed along and her
back lit on fire and i gave her food
washing
and i laid my hands in the cool water
and i saw someone drowning in a pool
and i pulled him up died by his dick
and i said dick tracy and he went to new
york
and stayed in new jersey
new jersey is the floodway of
the new york hudson river
it has so much pollution
that children are backlogged
up to 30 years for getting their test
results
and i said don't say bad
and i saw my spine in
pre-elementary that's before you've gone
outside
you're held like a fat piece of chicken
and when they see you going outside and
the red doors are open
those are bar burners that means you're
going to need a drink in about three
minutes
and we didn't get one and we turned into
the 1922
death bowl and we were given
sanctuary by
wild rock that's also people who know
that they can't get a drink evelyn
yeah is there anyone that takes care of
you here in the street any
are there any of the homeless uh
organizations that uh that are here
helping people or
you have no family i assume that's
helping you no one's helping you
well uh you don't have a tendency the
marathoners helped me the most
people running in shorts going over
brick
stopping in irish or swedish bars
where do you go to eat i
don't eat i make food and then if it
returns
to me i'll think of my bike
and i'll put the brakes on and i'll lay
the food down then if i see
mexican jumping beans i will eat them
and
tacos i could gobble up the world
but the word health or skelter
came to me and
i was hit in the back of my noggin
with a baseball bat when i feasted on
those
black eyes toes so i know they've held
the bat
why this is a funny one a man walked
down the street with a short little
attention span
you can call me out or you can call me
betty and that makes cake
or someone left a cake out in the rain
eyes on things that i can take it
cause it took so long to make it and
i'll never have this recipe
again again
someone left a cake out in the rain
i don't think that i can take it
a rain took so long to bake it and i'll
never
have this recipe again
again
you're amazing evelyn oh thank you
you're so interesting oh thank you are
you happy
uh yeah when i look at equipment
when something's going on then i am but
when people
stop or uh
they take the litter out on the road and
kick it to death
you know making those little blondes
with the scrawny arms or spilling the
milk shaking fries
mexicans don't get much to eat they rely
on ocean beach survivors
i like to think when i swam that
it was 11 people
maybe even doing it but you know
you get so blinded by the harsh
conditions
uh 17 years of rain
in one backyard your kids washed away
coming in stomping on your trousers
you know do you ever get depressed
living on the street like 17 years ago i
was
i thought i was going to be the only one
living on earth
and i said i repent and the band was
waiting for me
and they dropped me off at a national
park and they were cooking burgers
people were
waiting i said just grab one and they
did and somebody's cigarette
uh got wet by it and another guys went
out
and i said boy this is the saddest
creation i've ever seen we've got to fan
out
so they took me back to this emporium
i'll call it now
now that i know money mart
and i was reliving my days of eating and
the van drove off
i had to walk into san jose
evelyn what was your favorite memory in
your life being at
t.s eliot's opening of jerry seinfeld's
why the devil ate my baby i said that's
an
early name for chocolate and i
immediately got home the states had
released me
i said it's not new information and
again i was taken i was on top of the
ski board and i had to dive in to get
television back on and
again i was in the national park and i
had to walk
out on a dirt road and i met some people
and
they gave me a granola bar and i didn't
lay it down i had to walk for 71 days
and when i got home there was a little
store there
and people were hitting each other and
they grabbed me by the back of her hair
and i said all right i'll lay down the
granola bar
and i didn't the black woman came over
for me and she took my pipe
and she smashed it to the ground so i
went on a worldwide search
and i ended up in front of a taco shack
and i didn't order a taco i knew i
didn't have the funds to pay for
being without a pipe
and i said um are you the mexican
i said how do you make it last
i said these paper plates are clogged
you must be here at
three in the morning and she said i am
and she watched a tear like this
i said you just said [ __ ] yourself.
i said i'm going to take my shoes off
and leave them for you and i walked back
to the office
and i found a pair of shoes and i was
behind a fence and the officers came
up and i said so i creep
creep i just creep around without you
i just creep until i'm feeling fine
and we walked all over that neighborhood
together
and i laid down lipstick i was tired of
them they're
paranoid you know they get kicked in the
ass so hard
i mean baseball is
like um
a killing field
and i was playing the game i remember
that game
she still won't come home
and i said that and i was behind whole
foods
and i said i wonder if people are
stealing that dry bread that makes the
beds creek
and i said you need some grease in there
and i
looked up and there was a full portrait
whole foods with
a circle about seven to twelve inches
long
and the generator was closed
evelyn what yeah what
what's my worst memory i'll fill in for
you thank you
being on a sex date being trapped by
automatic machines seeing people follow
me
and not knowing what to say
i said if you had said stalker you would
have startled that street
and they would have followed her i said
i'd like them to follow me
and i was in a castle
and these are people who forget their
life
so i said one fun day
and i saw a penny laying on the ground
and i knew it was emergency equipment
and i said it's a really loud boisterous
name
i said i've got to tell you something i
said
these dinners that these nurses are
getting are making
17 foot doors i said i'd been down to
the office
he said oh the office
he said oh i've got and he handed me a
20 bill
and i started crying right away and i
knew it was the front of the church
doors
so i said the poetry man
then i said angrily they stomped about
and i said jesus
i've seen you all my life i just had a
little rabbit coat to
start out with if you want me you can
think of bowling
and i was in bowling green kentucky's
waiting to become a
naval audio crap
i thought they knew sound waves
and i got some saying that day
and it's sick in my legs i was on a
tanker up in alaska
evelyn yeah but how long have you been
smoking crack
for 61 years
how old are you 61.
you started early yeah
well i needed something to recover those
banana tables
we were having luaus in hawaii the men
would jump off
cliffs thinking it was a blue-eyed girl
i baked so many muffins that day
24 rounds and then i got here to san
francisco
and i found out that the chocolate chip
outsold the blueberries
i see a man
and i said i'm addicted to paper
and i'm um
i'm reading so much that my retina
detaches
and the ambulance says um
we have your hip replacement i said i've
done this two times
you've already told me that i get up and
get out too much
i said all i want is a drink of water
and they put men's balls in a little
bowl and i say
honey um
this tank that i rolled up in i said
north to alaska i said that dog is so
broken down
and i said mama handed me money
but i know it's just a little notebook
i said when my son and i died in each
other's arms
i became a black woman
but i didn't eat ice cream
and i only ate two of them so i know i
sometimes so when i think of
marshmallows
and i said those are breaks and i wanted
to dance so bad
that i said um saint anthony's
and i wanted him milk
and he wouldn't let me pick it up so i
said um
well if i can't strip for you then you
can have my saggy tit
and he started stirring around and i
said um
when i get dreadlocks and he picks up my
beer
that was on a large island children are
not wanted on
islands they're heavy drifters
they don't like trains either they use
towels they smack blondes on the behind
and i was singing with don hoe and she
wouldn't let me kiss him
and i said now i don't have any love
she said we have been on this island
since the year
1900. women come in and drink our wine
when we are rested they come into our
room
and take our and i said
my life is the same as yours
i said let's start yelling and they all
left the room
and i went to a bathroom and i laid on
my back and it was
chilly and i knew i made a restaurant
with automatic dispenser
and he stuck his [ __ ] so far down my
mouth
that i knew it was a broom being handled
i said you can't wait to get a hold of
my leg
i said these floors have leaves on them
these are
shoes these are
shoes that you're sweeping up
evelyn yeah do you remember your family
yes i do all three brothers and six
sisters they hadn't graduated
i'm using up my college education right
now
but i remember hunting my french classes
learning that it was just a cigarette
that yes you could make a country with a
cigarette
that your eyes would become dull to them
after your fifth
that's 52 strokes from a machine gun
evelyn when's the last time you saw any
members of your family
18 years ago one day before
the stroke of midnight that's when the
glass grows 12 feet high
at midnight so i wasn't falling asleep
and i said
so so so and i said stephen king
is your father and i got back to the
brick wall and i still hadn't had a
drink
it's going on 33 hours now
and i faint and i get down humbly
like this and i said lord why have you
forsaken this child
and he looked out and i could see
lottery tickets falling to the ground
and she says um oh
i knew that she the white girl was just
as violent as the black man
and there were a group of men behind
they said get away from her
and they followed me down the street and
knocked me in the back of my balls
and i said do you want to have sex
and he came i always do
because i don't have a racial bone in my
body i
love black girls for their early youth
you know about they are backpacks some
of those backpacks do have words in them
like um i need a little breath of fresh
air
or don't take that i saw that already
and you walk out i put a backpack down